THE UNITED STATES DONALD J.
TRUMP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT TO BE IN THIS WONDERFUL
STATE SO MANY FRIENDS SO MUCH
SUCCESS AND WE LOVE BEING HERE.
AND WE'RE HERE ACTUALLY TODAY
TO DISCUSS THE EXCITING
PROGRESS THAT WE'VE ACHIEVED
UNDER THE OPERATION WARP SPEED.
OUR HISTORIC INITIATIVE TO
DEVELOP TEST MANUFACTURE AND
DELIVER A VACCINE IN RECORD
TIME AND THAT'S WHAT IS IN
RECORD TIME. LIKEWISE
THERAPEUTICALLY WE ARE VERY
VERY ADVANCED YOU'RE HEARING
ABOUT IT AND YOU'LL BE HEARING
ABOUT IT A LOT MORE IN THE NEXT
TWO WEEKS. WE WILL ACHIEVE A
VICTORY OUT OF OUR OFFICE BY
UNLEASHING AMERICA'S SCIENTIFIC
GENIUS WHICH IS WHAT IT IS. I
THEREFORE PROUD TO AND THAT
THIS MORNING. THE MODERN
VACCINE HAS OFFICIALLY ENTERED
PHASE THREE ALREADY. AND THAT'S
PHASE THREE CLINICAL TRIALS THE
FINAL STAGE BEFORE APPROVAL.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS IN TERMS OF SPEED
NOTHING EVEN CLOSE A SECOND
VACCINE IS LIKELY TO ENTER
PHASE THREE. IN A MATTER OF
DAYS UNDER OPERATION WARP SPEED
WE'VE SHAVED YEARS OFF OF THE
TIME THAT IT TAKES TO DEVELOP A
VACCINE IN SOME CASES FOR MANY
YEARS. AND WE'VE DONE IT WHILE
MAINTAINING THE FD GOLD
STANDARD FOR SAFETY. THIS IS
THE FASTEST A BANK. OR A NOVEL
PATH AS EVER GONE. THE GUN LIKE
THIS AND- IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE
WE ARE BY. PHASE THREE WE CAN
SAY EVER GONE BY FAR FOR
ADDITIONAL PROMISING CANDIDATES
ARE EXPECTED TO ENTER FINAL
TRIALS. IN THE COMING WEEKS
INCLUDING THE NOVAVAX VACCINE
BEING DEVELOPED. RIGHT HERE AT
THIS FACILITY IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE FACILITY WILL BE
MAKING A TOWARD A LITTLE WHILE
VERY- VERY COMPLETE TOUR WITH
FIFTY. FOLKS THAT RUN IT IN THE
THAT BREAK. WE JUST COMPLETE A
TOUR OF. INNOVATION LABORATORY
AND THAT'S TO BE DONE IT MUCH
YEAH MUCH HIGHER LEVEL IN A FEW
MINUTES AFTER I'M FINISHED I
BELIEVE WILL TAKE A FEW. TO
WHICH WERE CARRIED AT EIGHT
CRUCIAL MENU. PROCESS NEEDED TO
MAKE THE NOVAVAX VACCINE THIS
PRODUCTION IS MADE POSSIBLE BY
MY ADMINISTRATION'S ONE POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLAR AWARD. TO
NOVAVAX AS PART OF OPERATION
WARP SPEED IT LETS US DELIVER.
THE FINAL PRODUCT IN THAT TIME
THAT NEVER HAS BEEN THE CHIEF
ANYWHERE. AT ANY TIME FOR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. THE SAME
MANUFACTURING PROCESS SEES ARE
CONDUCTED ON AND LARGER SCALE.
IN COLLEGE STATION TEXAS TODAY
I'M PROUD TO ANNOUNCE THAT
HHS'S JUST DIED. TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY BILLION ON TRACK TO WOULD
YOU BILL THANKS. IT OF AGENTS
WHICH IS QUITE. TWO DRAMATIC
EXPAND THEIR BACK MAY TO. I
WANTED FOR CEO ME SEN FOR
WEALTH US TODAY AND MARTIN
WORRIES MARTIN THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ONE REALLY
WONDERFUL WITH YOU IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE ISN'T. WITH ALL
THE PROGRESS BEING MADE. AS AS
NUMBER THE BLACK SEA. STANLEY
STANLEY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY FOR BEING.
THANKS ALSO TO SECRETARY ALEX
DAYS ARE WHO'S WITH US SENATOR
THOM TILLIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU TOM STANDUP TULSA.
GOOD JOB YOU'VE DONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU REALLY HAVE.
REPRESENTATIVES RICHARD HUDSON
DAVID ROUSER MARK WALKER DAN
BISHOP AND GREG MURPHY THANK
YOU ALL FRIENDS WARRIORS.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN FOREST
WHERE IS DOING A GREAT JOB
WEDNESDAY AND STAND UP IN.
GREAT JOB DID REALLY GOOD NORTH
CAROLINA HOUSE SPEAKER TIM
MOORE. THANK YOU JIM GREAT JOB.
AND PRESIDENT PRO TEM OF THE
NORTH CAROLINA STATE SENATE
BERGER THANK YOU FEEL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED. OPERATION WARP
SPEED IS FUNDING A HISTORIC
PORTFOLIO OF HIGHLY PROMISING
VACCINE CANDIDATES IN ADDITION
TO R. ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN NOVAVAX
WE'VE ISSUED A FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE MILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT WITH THEIR ANNA. A ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
CONTRACT ASTRAZENECA A FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR CONTRACT WITH. SEN JUST
TWEAK IT ONE POINT NINE FIVE
BILLION OR AGREEMENT WITH VISOR.
AGREE MAY ALL OF THOSE.
COMPANIES ARE GROUND AGREEMENT
WITH VISOR INCLUDES A GARY TO
WHY HUNDRED DOLLAR. SHORTLY THE
APPROVAL ALMOST IMMEDIATELY.
WITH THE OPTION TO PURCHASE AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THEREAFTER NOT ONLY IS
OPERATION WARP SPEED
ACCELERATING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
A VACCINE WE'RE ALSO DIRECTING
A COLOSSAL INDUSTRIAL
MOBILIZATION TO ENSURE ITS
RAPID. DELIVERY NOW IS HAPPENED
LIKE THIS SINCE THE END OF
WORLD WAR TWO. INSTEAD OF THE
USUAL SEQUENCE OF VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT TESTING AND TRIALS
FOLLOWED BY PRODUCTION OUR
STRATEGY IS TO CONDUCT THESE
PHASES SIMULTANEOUSLY SO
EVERYTHING GOES AT ONE TIME.
WE'RE NOT WAITING AND WAITING
AND WAITING IT'S ALL GOING AT
ONE TIME. WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
IS. I THINK IT'S UNFAIR NEVER
BEEN DONE BEFORE BUT WE SUSPECT
IT'S GOING TO WORK AND WORK
VERY WELL. WERE MASS PRODUCING
ALL OF THE MOST PROMINENT
VACCINE CANDIDATES IN ADVANCE.
SO BUT ON THE DAY ONE THAT IT'S
A- IT'LL BE A VERY TO THEM.
PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY AND WILL
PROBABLY HAVE A LOT FOR. A LOT
OF OTHER PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD THE WORLD IS SUFFERING
FROM THIS CHINA VIRUS. ANOTHER
DIMENSION OF OPERATION WHAT
SPEED IS OUR FOCUS ON
THERAPEUTICS TO TREAT THE
VIRUS. OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY CLINICAL TRIALS UNDERWAY.
AND A NUMBER OF EFFECTIVE
THERAPIES OF ALL BEEN DEVELOPED
AND WIDELY DELIVERED. INCLUDING
RAM DEV SERVER HAVING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT YOU SEE THAT
WITH MORTALITY RATES AND OTHER
THINGS STATISTICALLY.
DEXAMETHASONE CONVALESCENT
BLOSSOM AND ANTIBODY TREATMENTS
WE HAVE NUMEROUS TREATMENTS
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE UNDER STUDY
AND I THINK OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS WE MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME VERY POSITIVE.
ANSWERS AS TO THAT ON JULY SO
WE CAN SAY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR AGREEMENT.
WITH REGENERON TO BEGIN
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING OF ITS
ANTIBODY TREATMENT JUST
CURRENTLY THANKS H. CLICK THE
GOLD LATE STAGE. DO THE MEDICAL
ADVANCES WE'VE ALREADY ACHIEVED
AND OUR INCREASE KNOWLEDGE AND
HOW TO TREAT THE VIRUS THE
MORTALITY RATE FOR PATIENTS
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. IS
85% LOWER THAN IT WAS IN APRIL
THINK OF THAT 85% AND THIS 25%
LOWER THAN EUROPE AS A WHOLE.
IN THE MIDDLE OF APRIL MORE
THAN 22% OF ALL DEATHS IN THE
UNITED STATES WERE DRIBBBLE TO
THE CHINA VIRUS. AS THE LAST
WEEK THAT NUMBERS DROP DOWN AS
OF LAST WEEK IT'S DROPPED DOWN
TO UNDER SEVEN PERCENT.
2 DEGREES THE GROUND TIME
SHOULD ASSUME. FIRST TWO HAVE
BEEN APPROVED. POOL TESTING
VERY IMPORTANT IN OTHER WORDS
SAMPLES ALL DOUBLE PATIENTS ARE
PROCESSED. THEY POOLED. TESTING
WILL REDUCE TURNAROUND TIME BY
MORE THAN SIXTY MORE THAN 4%
LAST OUR CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES BEGAN
DISTRIBUTING RAPID POINT OF
CARE DIAGNOSTIC TEST
INSTRUMENTS TO ALL OF THE
NURSING HOMES IN THE UNITED
STATES FOCUS ON THE AREAS OF
GREATEST NEED. ELDERLY AND- OR
NURSING HOMES WHAT IS ALREADY
SET INCLUDES TESTING
INSTRUMENTS TO SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE NURSING HOMES FOR
ONE HUNDRED NINETY SIX THOUSAND
RAPID POINT OF CARE TO. AMOUNT
THAT'S GET YOUR RISK IN ANSWER
FOR FIVE TO MINUTES. BUT THE
NEXT THREE WEEKS ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED SHARES MAJORITY
DIGITAL EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
POINT HERE TO REGULAR. IS
CONDUCTED A FIFTY MILLION S.
THAT'S MORE THAN OF YOU PUT
TOGETHER TIMES TO NOBODY'S EVEN
AND COUNTRY'S GO IT IS AS AN
EXAMPLE. INDIA IS UP ELEVEN
MILLION TEST WE'RE GOING TO BE
VERY SHORTLY AT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION TEST INDIA'S AVOID.
FOUR BILLION PEOPLE. THROUGH
OUR RELENTLESS WE'VE COMPLETELY
REBUILT OUR STOCKPILE WHICH THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
DEPLETED AND DID NOT REFILL.
THE CUPBOARDS WERE BARE- HI SAY
IT OFTEN IN TOTAL WITH NOW
DISTRIBUTED NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION N. NINETY FIVE MASKS
THIRTY FIVE MILLION SURGICAL
MASKS FIFTEEN MILLION FACED
THOSE AT. MUCH MORE. IN
ADDITION TO RENTAL LETTERS
ABOUT IF. THING OF ALL WE ARE
NOW BUILDING THOUSANDS A MONTH
AND WE'RE DISTRIBUTISM WE HAVE
ALWAYS IN OUR COUNTRY BUT TO
OTHER COUNTRIES THAT ARE IN
DESPERATE NEED. COUNTRIES ARE
HAVING A TREMENDOUSLY DIFFICULT
TIME WITH THE VIRUS. LAST WEEK
FEMA SAID TRADITIONAL PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND NURSING HOMES
INCLUDING SIX HUNDRED FORTY
THREE THOUSAND. PAIRS OF
PROTECTIVE EYEWEAR SEVEN
MILLION MASKS THIRTY FOUR
MILLION PAIRS OF GLOVES AND SIX
MILLION GALLONS IT'S A LOT.
OVER THE WEEKEND CASES FLORIDA
TEXAS AND ARIZONA HELD STEADY
AND ARE NOW HEADING DOWN. IN
ARIZONA THEY'RE HEADING VERY
SUBSTANTIALLY DOWN AND RAPIDLY
WE'VE BEEN CONSTANT AND IN
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION WITH THE
STATE'S. UNDER CERTAIN THING
THEM RESOURCES WHEN REQUESTED
THEY LARGELY HAD WHAT THEY
NEEDED BUT ANYTHING THEY NEED
RISK THEM IMMEDIATELY WE ARE
TOTALLY FULL WE HAVE EVERYTHING
WE NEED. TO THE STATE'S
IMMEDIATE WE DEAL WITH A- THE
REAL SHIP WITH THE IS BEEN VERY
GOOD. THESE ARE NOT A OF THE
WOULD. BUT RIGOROUS COMPLIANCE
WITH GUIDELINES GENERAL OUT OF
IT YOU TURN ORDER. WE AFFIRM IN
WITH THEIR GOVERNOR AND HEALTH.
THE COUNTRY A COMPLETE IN LIES
IN OUR THE DAY AS WELL AS-
RECOMMENDATION STATE'S
DIFFERENT. BIDEN TO IS ALL
APPLY BY THIS YEAR SURGING SLOW.
IN LATIN. WHICH IS NOW REGION
THE WORLD WITH THE MOST ACTIVE
REPORTED IN FACT BY. DO TO THE
RALLY SCARE OF AND LET THEM OUR
THE READ RICH DUMP OF CASES. IS
ALL LAW TO BE. DRUM UNDER
EITHER ON ACCOUNTED AND I CAN
SAY THAT TRUE THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE WORLD WE REPORT A CASE
IS ABOUT OF THE WORK DOES IT
THEY THE DAY DO TEN THERE FOR
THEY HAVE FEW K. IS EVEN THE
PEOPLE WHO THANK. OF CAJUN A
REPORT AND GIVE THE RE. OF WHAT
WE SAID WE'RE FOCUSING
AGGRESSIVELY ON. HIS BORDER AND
COUNTRY SAID. WE THEY CAP. VERY
CAREFUL BECAUSE YEAH SOME VERY
VERY EARLY AND FOR BECAUSE- OUT
OF OUR BORDERS. I'VE SPOKEN
WITH GOVERNOR ABBOTT DELIVERING
GENTLEMAN AND I CAN REPORT THAT
OVER THREE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED FEDERAL PERSONNEL ON
THE GROUND IN TEXAS WE'VE GIVEN
THEM A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
EXTRA HELP INCLUDING DOCTORS
NURSES FRONTLINE PEOPLE WE'VE
SUPPLIED TEXAS WITH MORE THAN
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION GLOVES
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND GOGGLES
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SURGICAL GOWNS ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION. THANKS
WHAT POINT THREE BILLION END I.
REST AT A MILLION K. N. MAY.
BEGINNING THIS WEEK TEXAS
AWESOME OR IS. FIVE ON CASES OF
REP DISAPPEAR WHICH IS PROVING
VERY EFFECTIVE ENOUGH TO TREAT
THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
PATIENTS. IN ADDITION TO THE
CROSS BORDER SPREAD. THIS STAGE
OF THE PANDEMIC IS BEING FUELED
BY YOU. CAN TO GENERALLY LITTLE
RISK OF BEING SERIOUSLY HARMED
BY THE STAGE. BUT K. AND READ
THE DISEASE IS WE NEED ALL
AMERICANS TO BE CONSCIOUS ABOUT
THEIR ACTIONS AND TO EXERCISE
AS A VIGILANCE. I TRUMP AMERICA
AND TO THE RIGHT THING STRONGLY
EVERY. ACTUALLY AS EARLY FOR
THIS ON MAINTAINING A OF THIS.
MAINTAINING RIGOROUS HI G.
AVOID LAW GET. AND GROUND INTO
A- AND WHERE MASS ONE OF. WE
ALSO DESTROY URGE CITIZENS TO
TAKE EXTRA PRECAUTIONS TO THE-
AT HIGHEST WE ARE. IN MORE
CASES IN MANY THE ELDERLY
ESPECIALLY. ELDER WITH MEDICAL
PROBLEMS SUCH AS HEART OR
DIABETES. WHAT YOU WANT TO
SHIELD THEM AND YOU WANT TO
GUARD THEM AND YOU WANT TO
PROTECT THEM FROM THE VIRUS
ESPECIALLY. ACTUALLY THE THAT
ARE. REALLY TARGETED ALMOST
TARGET YOU COULD SAY BY THIS
HORRIBLE HORRIBLE PLAGUE THIS
HORRIBLE EPIDEMIC PANDEMIC
AMERICA WILL DEVELOP A VACCINE
VERY SOON AND WE WILL DEFEAT
THE VIRUS WILL HAVE A DELAY IN
RECORD TIME. AS IN HERE ACT.
THANK ALL POLITICAL PRISONERS
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF NORTH
IS GREAT IS A GREAT PLACE IS
SAFE- I'M IN A PLACE AND. HOW
MANY THANK ME TO SET YOU TIME.
ONE OF DRY INTO J. DRIVE IN TO.
OF YOUR REPRESENTATIVE AND YOUR
PA. AS BEEN A- WHEN THEY CALL
ON THEIR ONE THEY CALL LOS OF
THEM MEN OF THEM AS HERE NOW. I
WILL ALWAYS THEIR CALL. SO
THANK VERY MUCH I YOUR BEING
HERE WITH US AND- I DON'T TO
QUESTION. FROM MENTAL THIS
BROUGHT BEEN MADE. IT'S BEEN
MADE RAPIDLY HAS BEEN MADE
AREAS THAT. NOTHING LIKE THAT
HAS TO PLACE BEFORE. SO PLEASE
GO YOU ARM. THANK YOU. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PHARMACIST
SAMANTHA HERE A VERY. HOLD
SINCE MARCH IS WE HAVE TO
EXTEND. THERAPEUTICS I CAN TELL
YOU THERAPEUTICALLY I THINK-
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS
WE'LL HAVE SOME REALLY VERY
GOOD THINGS TO SAY- WE'RE JUST
HAVING GREAT ACTORS SO IT IS
ABOUT THAT AND IT'S ALSO THE
VACCINE THAT WE DISCUSSED TODAY
AT EVEN GREATER LENGTH IS JUST
COMING ALONG REALLY. IT'S NOT
JUST ONE CUP IS COMPANIES
TREMENDOUS BROWN THAT'LL BE A
NEW OVER NEXT OF. WHAT POSITIVE
THINGS BUT BY THE END OF THE
WITH WE'RE IN VERY GOOD SHAPE
TO BE DOING THAT BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE IN
TERMS OF THE VERY. I INTO OF
THERAPEUTICS EVEN SORT OF THE-
IT EX MEETING YOU GO. AND
SOMEBODY WHETHER IT'S FOR. OR
SO WHATEVER BE. AND THEY HEAL
AND HE'LL GO. SO WE'VE HAD
TREMENDOUS PROBLEMS. WE ARE
HAVE IF YOU LOOK AT. READ THIS
IF. AND IF YOU LOOK SOME OF THE
OTHER THINGS BUT WE'LL HAVE.
WE'LL HAVE SOMEONE OUT SO THAT
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEAH. IT IS
BUT IT'S ONLY HOPE BECAUSE.
SUCH A BARRAGE. SCIENTIFIC YEAH.
ONE I WANTED ASK IF YOU DIDN'T
ABOUT. THE RECORDS. RUSSIA
HAVING DONE ON OVER AND EVERY
WE DON'T ABOUT WE BUT WE PLENTY
OF. AND I THINK IT WAS FOR PLAY.
EARLIER SAID FOR OF EASTER
BROKEN SHOWING SIGNS MODERATE.
DO YOU THINK GIVING WE'RE
SAYING WITH THE. COME UP WITH
SOME ANSWERS VERY QUICKLY WHICH
I THINK WE WILL- THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A TREMENDOUS
RECOVERY- LIKEWISE WITH THE
VACCINES IF YOU DO THAT BY THE
END OF THE YEAR THAT'S AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE SUBSTANTIALLY AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE. AND IS IT ANYTHING
THAT'S EVER TAKEN PLACE IN
TERMS OF THIS BEFORE SO I THINK
IF THINGS HAPPEN JUST ONE OF
THOSE EVENTS HAPPEN. YOU'LL GO
RIGHT BACK TO THAT. YOU'RE
PROBABLY IN THE VEHICLE AT. I
REALLY DO BELIEVE A LOT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S SHOULD BE OPENED UP
STATE'S AT- NOT OPENING. AND
SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH THEM WHAT
WILL HAVE TO THE FACT THAT
THERAPEUTICALLY I THINK YOU
HAVE SOME GREAT ANSWERS VACCINE
WAS. WAS I HAD THE BACK. SERVER
ANOTHER YOU CANCELED THE
JACKSONVILLE FORTUNATELY OUR-
DO YOU THINK COOPER MADE THE
RIGHT. WELL WE'RE ACTUALLY
COMING TO NORTH HAS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A VERY I GUESS THAT WOULD
BE THE NOMINEE I SO THAT'S MY
THAT'LL BE MONDAY THEY'RE GOING
TO BE HERE. AND TO THE REST
WILL DO IN A DIFFERENT FORM WE
COULD HAVE. DONE IT MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT I THINK WE
DID THE RIGHT THING AND- I'M
REALLY HAPPY THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE HAVING A PIECE OF IT AT
LEAST IN PART. IN ORDER. IS.
HERE NOW. WHAT'S YOUR PLANS
GOING FORWARD. IN FACT YOU'RE
THE RIGHT PERSON I THINK THE
POLL NUMBERS ARE VERY GOOD THAT
PHONE NUMBER WE HAVE A VERY
GOOD WOULD LEAVE IN NORTH. WILL
LEADING INTO. WILL BEING IN
ARIZONA OUR NUMBERS WERE
LEADING IN ARIZONA WITH LEADING
NICELY AND FAR. THAT WE GET A
LOT OF SUPPRESSION POLLS WE GET
A LOT OF FAKE POLLS JUST LIKE
WE HAVE FAKE NEWS OF IT IT'S A
TERRIBLE THING. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT IT BUT HAD THE SAME THING
FOR YOU. I WAS LOSING
EVERYWHERE I'VE- I WAS GONNA
WIN ANY STATE I ENDED UP
WINNING EVERY ONE OF THEM. YOU
KNOW THE SWING STATES I WAS
GOING TO WIN ANY OF AMID I WANT
ALL OF THEM. AND I HAVE THE
SAME THING THIS YEAR AND THIS
YEAR THEY- HAVEN'T EVEN CLOSER
THEY HAVEN'T CLOSER BUT- IT'S
THE SAME. CAN TYPE BALLS WE
HAVE POLLJUNE SHOW ME LEADING.
IN ALMOST EVERY SWING STATE.
AND SUBSTANTIALLY. IN OTHER
STATES BY EVEN MORE THAN I ONE
AND SIXTEEN. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
FLORIDA AS AN EXAMPLE YOU HAVE
THOUSANDS OF BOWED OUT OF ABOUT
WHAT'S OUT OF THE OCEAN. THE
INTERCOSTAL. YOU GET OTHER
STATES WILL BUT YOU HAVE HOUSE
INS OF. OATS AND THE ROLE. WAY
BEING THE TRUMP. TRUMP SIGNED
AND THEY'RE SO PROUD THAT.
MEANS IN. SENATE YOU HAVE
BIKERS. WITH BLOCKED FROM MY
LOG AND HIGHER IS GOING ON. WE
GET. IT IS MORE. THEN THIS. BUT
MY CAMPS AND THAT IT KINGSWEAR
ABI GREAT ENTHUSIASM RACE FOR
WE HAD SPIRIT I THINK THIS
TODAY BECAUSE- WHAT WE'VE DONE
NOBODY'S EVER DONE BEFORE
NOBODY IS EVER. REBUILT THE
MILITARY TAXES THE MOST IN OUR
HISTORY CREATED THE GREATEST
ECONOMY WE'VE EVER HAD CUT
REGULATIONS AT A LEVEL THAT
NOBODY'S EVER DONE AND ALL OF
THESE DIFFERENT THINGS THE VIET
GOT VH IS. AT THE THREE FOR VA
RIGHT NOW THEY HAD 21% OF
RATING IN A RECENT POLL I WAS
JUST SPEAKING TO THE SECRETARY
91% THE VIET THIS. POINT
BEFORE- I THINK PEOPLE SEE ALL
THAT WE DON'T SPACE FORCE WE
CREATE. FORCE ACTUAL- ARMY NAVY
AIR FORCE MARINES RIGHT AT
IT'S- AMAZING COAST GUARD AND
THAT SUCH FORCE. SO HOW IS THAT
BIDEN. THERE IS OVER BY THE WAY
WE'VE DONE HAS NEVER BEEN DONE
IF YOU LOOK AT ALASKA WITH AND
WHY OF THE BILL. FOR THE
BIGGEST DRAW SIDE OF THE WORLD.
EVEN WHAT REAGAN AND BUSH AND
CLINTON EVERYBODY WANTED TO GET
IT DONE I GOT IT DONE AND WATER
AND ALASKA PROBABLY A POSSIBLY
THE BIGGEST DRILLING SITE IN
THE WORLD. KNOW WHAT WE'VE DONE
HAS BEEN INCREDIBLE RECENTLY IT
LOOKS LIKE THE ENERGY BUSINESS
WAS GOING TO BE. A TEST OF THE
WE WERE NUMBER ONE IN THE WORLD
AND THEN WE HAD THE PANDEMIC
AND NOBODY WAS USING ENERGY
NOBODY WAS DRIVING AN
AUTOMOBILE. NO GET TO LATE
BOTTLED GASOLINE PRICES FOR
EVERYONE A VERY VERY LOW. IN
MANY CASES LESS THAN TWO
DOLLARS IT'S PRETTY INCREDIBLE.
AND I SAVE THE ENERGY BUSINESS
I GOT RUSSIA AND I GOT SAUDI
ARABIA ON THE PHONE. AND THEY
CUT WAY BACK AND WITH OUR-
FORTY DOLLAR. PLUS A BARREL.
AND WE'RE SAVING TENS OF INS OF
JOB UNDER G. WITH. ONE AND THEN
IT WORLD. WITH ALL WE'VE DONE.
WE MADE AND BROUGHT COUNTRY TO
THE GREATEST POINT. THIS WE
NEVER BUT I CAN'T. LIKE CAT.
THE CHOPPER. A GOOD FRIEND OF
OURS AND WE HAD NO LIKE IT.
GONNA AGAIN EVERY KNOWS I'M
GOING TO READ BILL IT I HAD A
CLOSE IT UP WE SAVE MILLIONS OF.
BY CLOSING IT WOULD IN CLOSE
YOU WOULD NUMBER THAT WERE HAVE
FIFTEEN TIMES. WOULD YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW ONE DEATH IS TOO MUCH
BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN TEN TO
FIFTEEN TIMES MAYBE MORE THAN
THAT WOULD YOU HAVE. WE CLOSE
THIS GREATEST ECONOMY EVER FAR
BIGGER THAN CHINA BETTER THAN
CHINA. JOHN WAS HAVING BY THE
WAY THE WEBSPHERE THEY HAD IN
SIXTY SEVEN YEARS TARIFFS THEY
PAID. AS A BILLIONS OF THE POST
THE WORST YEAR THEY'VE HAD
THINK OF IT. IT'S C. SEVEN
YEARS WE WERE HAVING THE BEST
YEAR WE'VE EVER HAD. AT A CLUB.
AND THAT. AND YEAR BE. THIS
YOURSELF IT'LL BE BETTER EVEN
THAN YEAR OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'LL BE HEADING BACK AND
I'LL SEE YOU BACK AT THE WHITE
HOUSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
GONNA TAKE AN ADDITIONAL TWO OR
OF THE PROCESS WITH THE YEAR.
THERE'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THE NORTH. IT MAY BE THAT WAY.